hey gq i am back this is the fahim
alexander philadelphia pennsylvania
home of the legendary philly beard today
i'm going to show you guys how to shape
up and maintain
curly textured beards
grooming curly textured bears requires
different
maintenance and grooming techniques to
shape up your curly beard
you would need a cool men's line shampoo
and conditioner
beard oil the blow dryer and comb
attachment
a powerful trimmer to shape up the beard
the razor
at the end to clean up the excess hair
off the cheeks
curly bears are harder to clean compared
to straight hair beards
curly beards hold more dirt and debris
step one shampoo and conditioning the
beard
when shopping for a shampoo make sure
you look for a product specifically
designed to shampoo
curly beards so what i'm using is the 12
men's line
shampoo which help gain moisture and
strengthen the hair
when shampooing the beard make sure you
use your fingertips
to exfoliate the beard and get
underneath the beard in the hair to get
to the skin
you're going to do this repeatedly until
you get all of the
access to breathe the oil and dirt from
the beard
and on the skin this will help minimize
ingrown hair and redness on the surface
of the skin
make sure you guys rinse well then onto
the conditioner
it's also important to use a conditioner
that's
great for curly beards make sure you use
a generous amount
of conditioner in the beard and let it
sit for 10 minutes
my favorite that i like to use is the 12
12
men's conditioner it softens the facial
hair without clogging the pores
now we're ready for step two fertilizing
the lawn
my lawn at home i like it to be green i
give my lawn at home its proper
nutrients so it can be
green so i compare that to my beard so
it can be nice
full thick and dark i'm going to give it
proper nutrients beard oil helps promote
natural growth helps prevent breakage in
ingrown hairs
it's very important to choose a beard
oil that's not too
thick because you don't want to clog
your pores it's definitely to choose a
beard oil that's not
overbearing far as the smell you don't
want to override your cologne
i usually use like four to six drops so
i can cover the whole lawn
exfoliating the beard getting the chin
getting the size getting underneath
preparing to pull that beard up
smells great the beard oil
adds an extra layer and moisture for
protection myself personally
i use my beard oil in the morning and
when i get home
after a shower i shampoo my beard i
apply
beard oil once again so i can sleep
through the night after shampooing the
conditioning
and rinsing the beard oil helps restore
the natural oils
in your beard it's very important to
keep your beard
moisturized because curly hair is easy
to break
and our next step will be blow dry step
three you want to pull out the beard
i know some of you guys out there
viewing this video that do not have a
blow dryer i
really recommend that you get one
blow dryers do not damage the hair
especially after you added the oil
as you can see using the blow dryer
makes your curly beard easy to work with
using this comb attachment helps pour
your beer out to its highest point
you definitely can blow dry your hair as
much as you want when it's damp
but it's very important learn your
temperatures
you want to keep your blow dry on a warm
temperature depending on how much hair
you have on your beard you want to turn
the heat up a little bit but not too hot
so you can burn yourself
the beard here is now pulled out and
relaxed ready to go into the next step
now that your beard is pulled out we're
ready for the shape up
step four lining it up
for this step you will need a well
adjusted trimmer
i'm going to use my caliber 22 stingers
what that means you want to have a well
calibrated
trimmer there's a lot of guys in the
barber community that are really good at
adjusting trimmers maybe you want to
contact one of them guys
to send your blaze off to get adjusted
it's very important
that you stay away from your natural
beard line
when shaping it up because you don't
want to cause
any irritation or any burns
so just stay low as possible i like to
start at the highest point
of my beard around the temple area then
i come down
gradually to a circular motion into
the mustache then i like to hit the
bottom of my mustache then on top
then i repeat the same process on the
other side
now it's very difficult to hit the sides
so you're kind of like if you have a
double mirror in your bathroom
you're going to use that and you're just
going to kind of like pour your hair to
the side
then you're going to go down cleaning
that excess hair up around your line
then down to your neck area clean that
excess hair off
until it's all cleaned off
it's an essential to have that double
mirror in your bathroom
to achieve those tight lines on your
curly beard
it's very important if you don't have
double mirrors to help prevent
irritation and bumps you want to stay
far away
from your natural line and just clean
underneath
in the back you kind of want to pour
your hair to the front
step 5 cut down the beard so after
that's done
i'm going to pick up my 44 fmj's which
stand for full metal jackets from
colliver
this clipper is very diverse and you can
use it on
any texture of hair a trimmer is
strictly used for
shaping up outlining and detailing of
the beard or the hairline
a clipper is strictly for cutting down
to your desired length on your beard or
on your hair
when trimming down the mustache you want
to use like a number one guard
fully extend the blade then just go
south with it
one guards are very very important i'm
going to trim down my mustache
i like to go freehand so i'm going to
start right below the temple
just even strokes down to the chin area
then i'm going to start on my other side
repeat the same
steps just making sure it's nice and
neat
now that my beard is all shaped up and
cleaned up and looking fresh and my
lines are tight
and even to the circular motion is
on to the last and final step step 6
finishing touches sometimes the trimmer
doesn't get the skin smooth enough so
you want to go behind it with a razor
so i like to use a razor to clean up
them extra loose hairs
this will allow you to get that close
shade while preventing
ingrown hairs and irritation
multi-blade razors are known to irritate
curly textured beards this model has
two blades that's made to minimize
contact
it's made for men with textured beards
and sensitive skin
it'll give you that close shave without
leading to ingrown hairs
[Music]
you guys have now graduated from your
beard course
make sure you follow these tips to keep
your textured beard
healthy and avoid irritation for more of
these great tips
or mel grooming you can follow me on my
instagram
father barber one